SPEAKER 1: My son played very
serious soccer when he was younger.
And at one point, he got a condition
called Osgood Schlatter, which
is essentially something that happens
when you're athletic and you grow.
He couldn't walk.
So we went to the pediatrician, who
pushed on his knee, he screamed.
And the pediatrician said,
he's got Osgood Schlatter.
Wait several weeks, he'll get better.
So we waited like two days.
And then someone told us that we
should go to see a specialist.
So we went into MGH to see a specialist.
The specialist pushed on his knee in
the exact right place, my son screamed.
The specialist said, he
has Osgood Schlatter.
But maybe we should get an MRI to
make sure nothing else is going on.
So we took him out to the
MRI machine up on Route 128.
He got the MRI.
We got the image.
We went back to the specialist.
The specialist looked at the
image and the specialist said,
he has Osgood Schlatter.
Everything else is fine.
Wait a few weeks and he'll get better.
So we waited a bit longer.
And his soccer coach said, you need
to go see the sports medicine doctor
at Children's.
So we took him in to the
sports medicine doctor.
The sports medicine doctor
pressed on his knee, he screamed.
said, he has Osgood Schlatter.
Wait a few weeks and he'll be better.
But by now we were kind
of in a few weeks anyway,
we only had to wait a little bit longer.
And true enough, a few weeks later, he
was actually better and all was good.
But all that consumption--
Passed the first pediatrician visit,
the specialist visit, the MRI,
the second specialist visit, the
visit to the sports medicine person.
All those things were probably
visits we might not have done
had we actually had to pay.
So all of that consumption
probably would fit
under the category of moral hazard--
Things that we did because it was free.